ACE NASSRI: My name's Ace.
I'm in Developer Programs
Engineer here at Google Cloud,
and today we're going
to be talking about how
to keep up with serverless.
So design pattern evolutions
for the scalable future.
So first I wanted
to take a moment
to clear up some
confusion on what
we mean when we say serverless.
A lot of people think
when you hear serverless,
oh that's compute,
that things like
AWS Lambda, or Azure Functions,
or Google Cloud Functions.
But here at Google, we define
serverless as a little bit more
broadly than that.
So in particular, when we're
talking about serverless
we're referring to
any platform that
has the following traits,
saying not just compute.
So the first of these traits
is plug-and-play auto-scaling,
which essentially means that
no matter how many requests you
throw at this thing
it'll scale up
and scale down within reason.
The second key trait
of serverless platforms
is that they
support what's known
as scale-to-zero behavior.
So this means that
essentially if you
don't direct any requests
at your serverless platform
that it will not charge
you for that period.
So not only do they scale up
and scale down based on load,
they can also scale
down to the point
where they won't charge
you if you don't actually
direct any you load at them.
So this combined with the
typical low to no configuration
experience of many of
our serverless platforms
means that they have a uniquely
low initial cost to get
started on, especially
if you're developing
a totally new application.
Now, last but not least
serverless platforms
are provider managed.
And what this means is back
in the old days if you wanted,
say, a NoSQL database,
you had to worry
about the infrastructure
underlying that database as
well as the database itself.
Nowadays we can
say, OK, hey Google,
give me a NoSQL database.
I don't want to worry about
the underlying infrastructure,
I want you to take care of that.
And Google can say, yes,
that's something we can do,
that's called Cloud
Firestore, Cloud Datastore.
So a couple other
things I wanted
to cover in terms of high
level caveats with serverless--
and this is all
background by the way,
we'll get to the good
stuff in a couple slides.
So the first high
level caveat here
is that the way serverless
does scalability
is sort of no questions asked.
I'll get into more
detail about this
later, but suffice to say
that this can backfire.
Second, the
additional abstraction
inherent in the
serverless model means
that it's typically
easier to use
and easier to get started
with, but it's also
less visible and
configurable when
it comes to your deployments
versus, say, the infrastructure
as a service model.
So quick plug for
serverless hosting on GCP.
I just want to take
the opportunity
to level set everyone
in the audience
as to what our products are.
So off to the left we have
our functions offering,
Google Cloud Functions,
and those essentially
take tiny snippets of code
and scale those to whatever
the demand may be.
to the right of that we
have App Engine, which takes
applications-- effectively
sets of URL routes
that map to functions.
To the right of that, we have
our newest surveillance product
called Cloud Run,
which will allow
you to run containers in a
serverless and scalable manner.
Now, those three are sort
of true serverless options,
if you will, because
they support all three
of those traits.
To the right of that we have
some serverless-like options
such as Cloud Run on GKE--
Google Kubernetes Engine-- or
perhaps even raw GKE itself,
and those are not
quite serverless
because they don't have
all of those traits.
In particular they require
some degree of management,
they are not provider managed.
But they have some
of those traits,
so they're sort of
serverless-like in nature.
Now, when you're
trying to decide
which one of these products
is right for you, of course,
there could be reams
written about the subject.
But generally what you want to
do is start off to the left,
start off with the
most abstract option,
and then work your
way right as you
find that the abstract
options don't fit
your needs for whatever reason.
So enough about the intro.
I wanted to take some time now
to go over some common patterns
that we'll see
within our patterns
ourselves, sort of
meta-patterns, if you will.
So the first common
trait that we're
going to see in
these patterns today
is we're going to see lots
of asynchronous behavior,
we're going to see lots of
things like message queues.
Second, we're going to
see lots of decomposition.
So we're going to take
these large tasks,
decompose them into
many smaller ones
that can then,
third, be distributed
amongst a series
of many machines.
So fourth, we can have
non-serverless components
in our serverless architectures.
There are a lot
of caveats to this
which we'll touch on in a later
slide, but suffice to say,
yes, it can be done.
And last but not least,
I kind of alluded
to this in the previous
slide, self-hosted primitives
like databases are increasingly
becoming provider managed.
And the so-what of that
is you, the developer,
is less concerned
about the ops and more
concerned about whatever
the platform does.
So you're not
thinking of this as,
oh, this is a NoSQL database
running on a Linux instance,
you just-- this is
a NoSQL database.
That's it.
So in terms of the
benefits of these patterns,
the first big benefit is
that distributed architecture
gets a lot easier compared
to the pre-serverless world.
So when it comes to things like
Kubernetes and orchestration,
they're increasingly
becoming sort of optional.
If you want that
fine grained control
you can get it through
things like Knative.
But if you're like me, you just
want to deploy an application,
have it scale, then you can
rely on things like serverless
to kind of abstract that
ops, that orchestration away
for you.
And of course, distributed
architecture primitives
are no different.
They are also transitioning
to serverless just
like the general cloud
primitives, as well.
And last but not
least, these serverless
distributed architectures
are more or less just as
scalable as the old school
distributed architectures.
So we don't really lose that
much in terms of scalability
by moving to serverless.
And another thing I
wanted to touch on here
is that separation of
concerns gets a little easier.
Or rather, there are
things we can do now
with serverless to increase
our separation of concerns.
So oftentimes separation
of concerns is helpful.
It will make your
code base easier
to work with, and to go
through, and to maintain.
Not always, sometimes
it can backfire.
This is one of those things
where it might make sense
for you, it might not.
Judge based on your
particular fact situation.
And of course, serverless
and these other new patterns
like the microservice
pattern allow
us to achieve higher degrees of
separation in our code bases.
And now that we've talked about
some of the motivating factors
behind serverless,
some of why we do it,
I wanted to take a moment
to touch on the things
that we want to change going
into the serverless world.
So of course there are some
things we want to change,
but there are also
things we want to keep.
And because we're all
positive people here
we're going to focus on the
things we want to keep first.
So the first thing
we want to keep
is the presence of this idea
of separation of concerns.
So in particular, we probably--
if you're coming from the old
application development world,
you might have heard
of this M/V/C idea.
And essentially
what that is is you
take a client
facing application,
you break it down
into three components,
you have your models, your
views, and your controllers.
Now for those of you who are
not familiar with this model--
no pun intended--
basically what happens is
your models are your database
schema, your views
are your front end,
and then your controllers
are essentially
your business logic.
Now of course this was a
step in the right direction,
but for reasons we'll get
into later we can actually
do better than this pattern.
Another thing that
we want to keep
is how we do distributed
architecture.
So we knew back then
that it could give us
less coupling and higher
throughput compared
to non-distributed
architectures,
and we also knew that it
was one of the few ways
to truly scale our
application simply
because vertical scaling
can only work up to a point
more or less given
technological restrictions,
and after that our
only other option is
horizontal scaling which is
by definition a distributed
system.
The last thing I
wanted to touch on here
is how we do things
in the front end.
You might be familiar with
this idea of thick clients.
Basically you take all
your business logic
and instead of putting
it on the back end
you kind of move most of
it towards the front end.
Now, it turns out
that serverless
allows us to create uniquely
lightweight back ends which
can be a natural fit for
things like thick clients
and single page apps.
So as I said, serverless
back ends naturally
fit these existing
front end techniques.
So in terms of
the things that we
do want to change, the
things that we might want
to do differently when
we move to serverless,
the first is the
client-facing app
patterns and app
design patterns have
improved a little bit since.
Like I said, it turns out
we can use other patterns
to achieve a greater degree
of separation of concerns
than we can with the model
view controller approach.
Also, distributed
systems back then
were notably harder
to implement.
Principally, you had to worry
about ops and/or orchestration.
You probably had to worry
about things like Kubernetes
or unmanaged components within
your distributed system, right?
Now, also another thing
was back then there
were no real tools for doing
lightweight event processing--
or excuse me, lightweight yet
flexible event processing.
The best you could do was
something like if this
then that.
Which is good as long as its
WYSIWYG approach contains
whatever you're
trying to get done,
but the second that it
doesn't you more or less
can't just write raw code on
top of something like that.
So adding your own custom
logic, like I said,
meant writing your entire
application from scratch.
So that begs the question, well,
what does serverless change?
What does serverless
bring to the table
that is inherently different
than this pre-serverless world?
So the first thing
to bear in mind
is that serverless is more
capital E evolutionary
than capital R revolutionary.
So the serverless
way naturally is
more of an evolution of old
approaches than a completely
new approach in and of itself.
Distributed systems,
the way those work
is you're starting
to see increasingly
serverless versions of core
distributed systems primitives.
So things like caches, message
queues, so on and so forth.
And you're starting
to see the high level
architectural principles
actually not change.
They more or less
stay the same when
you move from this
non-serverless distributed
architecture to the
serverless variant.
And as a hands-on demo of
what this looks like, so let's
say we have a pretty canonical
distributed system here.
It just kind of accepts a
stream of image resize requests,
uses a message queue
to load balance
those across some
set of compute units,
and those compute units will
then resize those images
and do something with them,
whether it's returning them
back or storing them in some
sort of storage or something
like that.
Now, this is the old
school way of doing things.
We had our message
queue presumably
running on some sort of
infrastructure as a service.
So this might be like
RabbitMQ or whatever.
And then that was load
balancing amongst a bunch
of compute units,
which in this case
are raw Compute Engine VMs.
Now, the downside of this
is we have to still worry
about that ops component.
Yes it works, yes it's
scalable, but we still
have to worry about the
GCE or GKE ops workload.
So if we move to the serverless
version of this, of course
we have less of
that ops concern.
But the beauty of this is that
we can kind of transliterate
these non-serverless components
over here pretty much
just to serverless
components off the bat.
We're not even
saying, OK, well we
have to do anything different
with our message queue,
or we have to do
anything different,
use some sort of different
version of compute.
All we're doing is we're taking
a non-serverless component,
swapping it out for a
serverless component.
And once we make that change,
making any required code
changes to mesh
the two together.
And for reference, the products
on the right here, essentially
what we're doing is we're
taking, again that message
queue that is running on
infrastructure, swapping it out
with its serverless alternative
which is something like Google
Cloud Pub/Sub.
We're taking the
serverful compute
and swapping it out
with serverless compute,
which in this case
is Cloud Functions.
So in terms of what else is
new, so web front end ideas--
I kind of already
touched on this--
also already fit this
service world quite well.
So notably, things like HTML
templating and static file
hosting haven't really changed.
CDNs, whatnot, they're
all still relevant.
But thick clients is really
where serverless kind of
comes into its own.
The idea of a thick client--
a thick front end is not new.
But once you pair that with
the thin back ends afforded
by serverless,
this means you can
get really good meshing
between your front end
and your back end.
So as an example of how
this works in the real world
or with a contrived problem,
admittedly, so let's
say we have this
example pet store here.
So there are a couple
different actions
that the users can take.
Those are all our views on the
front end, the list, buy, cart
and pay URLs, and then
we're backing this
with a monolith running on
GKE for its back end compute,
and then we have a bunch
of primitives or components
of to the right here.
So you'll see there
that the first component
in that list of primitives
is a SQL database.
Now, if you're
thinking, OK, well I
want to scale this thing,
that SQL database can scale up
to a point but I'm not going to
be able to horizontally scale
that.
I'm eventually going
to hit a bottleneck
and I'm going to have to get
rid of that SQL database.
You might think, OK, well I can
just migrate that SQL database
to a NoSQL alternative
and boom, I'll
have horizontal scalability.
And that is correct.
This application as it
is, if you architect it
in the right way, is
horizontally scalable.
It will scale up and
scale down to meet demand.
But it's not
entirely serverless.
You still have to worry about
things like orchestration
and ops because you have
your serverful compute,
you have your
serverful primitives.
But if you want to abstract
that ops workload away,
if you want to start moving
towards serverless, what you
can do is say, OK,
well, I'm going
to start with the primitives.
And again, like we did
in the previous example,
we can transliterate
those primitives-- not
even translate, transliterate
those primitives--
from their serverful options
to their serverless options.
So we might look at
this and say, well,
we have a NoSQL database
and we have a log service.
And those are serverful,
those are running
on some sort of infrastructure.
Now, what is a
serverless log service?
Something like
Stackdriver Logging.
What is a service
NoSQL database?
Something like Cloud
Datastore, Cloud Firestore.
So it turns out if we just
do that transliteration
and then update our code
accordingly we can say,
OK boom, we've got
our primitives running
on serverless.
We've more or less
reduced our ops workload
by migrating everything.
But there's still the elephant
in the room, or rather
the elephant in the
architecture here,
which is that monolith
in the middle.
So if you wanted
to do a simple--
well, not so simple--
if you wanted
to do the easiest
possible lift and shift
to get onto serverless,
you might say, well,
maybe I want to put that on
some sort of raw serverless
compute option like Cloud
Run or maybe App Engine.
Cloud Run would
probably be ideal
if you wanted the least effort
lift and shift for something
like a GKE cluster.
But you're in the
situation where you're
dealing with a thick client.
You say, OK, well, maybe
we should take the time
to re-architect this so we can
really take advantage of not
only serverless
but the advantages
afforded to us by this thick
client on the front end.
So what you can do is
say, well, if we're
going to go the extra
mile, let's go ahead
and migrate this to something
like Cloud Function,
some sort of serverless
compute option.
And by doing that not only do we
get the benefits of serverless
in terms of ops and
scalability, but we
build an architecture
that is better
suited to this idea of
the thick client front end
as opposed to having
this massive back end
and this massive front
end where there's also
all sorts of logic
duplication, all sorts
of additional maintenance,
all sorts of bad things
that you're doing on both
for really no good reason.
So in terms of what
else is new, what's
changed a little bit
in terms of abstraction
is back then we only
really had one option,
and that was infrastructure.
So that meant that
we had more work,
but we also had more
control and visibility
over our deployments.
Nowadays, the
beauty of serverless
is that it strictly gives
us additional options.
So in terms of
serverless options,
they give us a lower
getting started
point, a lower minimum in terms
of the work that we have to do.
But if we want that
additional control
and additional visibility we
can still say, hey, serverless
isn't right for me,
I want these things
so I'm going to go off
towards the infrastructure
side of things.
And as I mentioned earlier
with the default cost model,
it has changed a little bit.
For non-serverless
platforms, it used
to be we would set
a billing limit
and then we would
fail at that point.
So once we hit that
quota, we basically
serve the user a quota exceeded
error or something like that.
And the beauty of that is if we
got a sudden deluge of requests
that we didn't want to fulfill--
say it was a denial of service
attack or a bug in our code--
then this is the
right approach and we
wouldn't be charged
for filling requests
that we didn't fulfill.
Nowadays, the approach
with serverless
is essentially scale
now, pay later.
Now, this approach
works well when
you get the sudden deluge
of legitimate requests.
Say, for example, your marketing
team knocks it out of the park
and you come into work
next day, and you pick up
your copy of your favorite
national newspaper,
and your app is right
there on the front page.
And suddenly everyone in
the country or everyone
across the world is
trying your application,
and your user base has
gone up by like 10, or 50x,
or whatever.
In that sort of
situation, you want
to make sure that your
application can scale up
to handle that demand
rather than serving all
of your new users
a bunch of quota
exceeded errors, because that
leaves a very bad impression
as to your application.
So the one thing
I do want to note
is that these are defaults,
they can be changed.
So if you are in
a situation where
you're using
non-serverless but you
want it to have that
unrestricted scaling
capability, you can do that.
If you're also in
a situation where
you want to use
serverless but you
want to restrict its
ability to scale,
that is something
you can do as well.
So now I'm going to touch on the
good stuff, the actual design
patterns that we're
going to be using
in the serverless environment.
So first of all, a quick
intro into the things
that have changed.
So the first design pattern that
we do a little bit differently
is how we do busy wait.
So back in the old
days, we used to be
able to rely on
things like callbacks
or blocking calls
and kind of wait
around for long running
tasks to complete.
Nowadays, we try to rely more
on message passing and things
like callbacks with their
own separate endpoints,
which I'll show
in the next slide.
So in terms of what this looks
like with a hands-on example,
the old school way
of doing things
might be to say, OK,
well, we're going
to do some effectively
instantaneous operation
like getting a user ID.
Then we're going to
kick off some slow, long
running external operation,
and then we're going to wait.
We're going to
walk around stage,
take a sip of our coffee,
twiddle our thumbs,
whatever, go to the bathroom.
And then once that
operation is done,
now bear in mind while we're
waiting this operation,
we still have that Cloud
Functions instance running.
That is still reserved, that is
still costing us compute time.
Now that that operation is
done, then we write the result
to the database.
Now, there are two big
problems with this.
One, the first thing
is Cloud Functions
has a nine minute
timeout at most.
So if this slow
external operation
takes longer than
nine minutes, what
will actually end up happening
is something like that.
That last line of
code will not execute,
your function will
throw a timeout error,
and it will cease execution.
Now, the second problem is that
even if this operation does
complete, even if it, say,
take six or seven minutes,
you're still paying for seven
minutes worth of compute
where you're not
really doing anything
during those seven minutes.
You're just kind of
sitting around waiting
for this operation to complete.
So of course that was then and
this begs the question, well,
how can we do this
in a better way?
So it turns out we can
do it in a better way.
So what we want to do
is essentially take
all of our instant operations,
our synchronous operations,
and put them in one function.
And then we want to take
that slow external operation
and turn it into some sort
of asynchronous alternative.
Now, there are a couple
ways we can do this.
Some operations such as those
with the Data Loss Prevention
API give us the ability
to pass in a Pub/Sub
topic that will then
be notified when
that operation is complete.
So we essentially say, hey,
slow external operation,
when you're done can
you publish a ping
to this topic-- my topic?
And that slow external operation
says, yeah sure, I can do that,
and I can also include this ID
as metadata if you want me to.
So once we do that we
can say, OK, great,
I'm going to go to sleep now.
This Cloud Function
is going to go
to sleep now after kicking
off this external operation,
and it doesn't matter how long
that external operation takes.
Once it's done, that Pub/Sub
message will be fired
and it will trigger the second
Cloud Function that writes
this result to the database.
And again, in this
case this solves
both of those two problems.
It solves the timeout
problem because once
that slow external
operation is kicked off
this Cloud Function can
exit and say I don't
have to do anything anymore.
If it takes all of
100 milliseconds
to kick that operation
off, then you're
being charged for 100
milliseconds plus whatever
it costs to get the user ID.
You're not being charged
for the amount of time
that the operation is running.
And second, even
if that operation
takes an hour you don't have
to worry about that timeout
because this Cloud Function
is only running for however
long it needs to get that ID
and kick off the operation,
not actually wait for the
operation to complete.
So the next pattern
I want to touch on
is how we do session affinity.
And basically the idea
with this is back then
we could rely on session
affinity, which essentially
means that if a user
sends, say, 10 requests,
that those 10 requests will
all go to the same machine.
You might be using a
distributed architecture,
you might have
thousands of machines
across your entire
application, but each user
will always go to the
same machine more or less.
Nowadays with serverless, that's
increasingly not available.
So a user's request may
hit different machines,
and this affects how
we're going to store state
through those user requests.
The second thing I
wanted to touch on here
is explicitly machine state.
Not just user state, but
the state of the machines
themselves.
So back then we could
also rely on things
like persistent machines.
We could rely on saying, OK,
I want to save this to disk,
or I want to say
this to RAM, and I
can trust that when
the user comes back
that it'll still be there.
Nowadays, we're
increasingly moving
to ephemeral architectures.
So there are no guarantees
in terms of where
the user is going to land.
They might make 10
different requests--
or excuse me, they might
make 10 different requests,
and the machine could start up,
and shut down, and start up,
and shut down 10
different times.
Even if you have
session affinity,
even if it goes through the
same machine every time,
it doesn't really matter
because if that machine was
provisioned, and
deprovisioned, and provisioned,
and deprovisioned, then those
deprovisionings can wipe state
from that machine.
And of course, going
back to session
affinity a little bit,
that is doubly a problem
because even if you have
those persistent machines
it doesn't really
matter if the user could
hit 10 different machines
across 10 different requests.
So the solution to
both of these problems
is you're going to want
to persist your data
outside of your actual compute.
So once that request is
done, maybe you send it off
to some sort of cache
or you send it off
to some sort of Cloud Datastore,
or something like that.
The idea is you're not
relying on any state
within the serverless
compute option itself
because that state is
essentially ephemeral.
So a couple more things
I wanted to touch on
in terms of design patterns.
So first, how we do retries
has changed a little bit.
So retriable operations, it
used to be we kind of had
to have our own doctor node,
if you will, that would say,
OK, this operation failed.
I'm going to go
retry that and I'm
going to keep trying this
operation until it succeeds.
Increasingly, that
is being offloaded
to serverless alternatives such
as serverless message queues.
So we can use things like
Pub/Sub and Cloud Tasks
as our sort of artificial doctor
nodes where they will say,
OK, I'm going to retry this
operation-- for example,
for Pub/Sub, I'm going to
try this operation until you
actually acknowledge
receiving my message.
And if your operation
fails you simply say,
OK, I'm not going to acknowledge
that Pub/Sub message,
and it will
automatically send me
another copy of that
message when it's ready.
Now, another thing
that changes--
I kind of alluded to this in
some of the previous slides--
but it's how we
can take advantage
of separation of concerns.
So used to be back
then we would rely
on something like
the M/V/C approach,
the model view controller model.
Nowadays we can take
advantage of what's
known as the
microservice pattern,
and this is a little
bit of a buzzword which
we'll explain the next slide.
But essentially what it
means is that we can achieve,
like I said, that greater
separation of concerns.
So in terms of what this
microservice term actually
means, what we're talking about
here is the idea that apps
are collections
of small services.
So each service has its
own narrowly scoped purpose
as well as its own code base.
Now, how you store these
code bases is highly
dependent on your
particular situation,
but some common patterns that
we've seen you might say,
OK, well I want to
put all of my code
for my application in one
giant version control repo
and then have a
bunch of directories,
each directory corresponding
to a microservice.
You might also say in
your situation, maybe
it's easier to set up
CI/CD in this manner--
continuous integration
deployment-- you might say,
OK, I want to put each of
these services in its own repo.
Whatever situation
makes sense for you
that's what you should do.
There is no one
right answer here.
Now, some of the benefits
of this microservice pattern
versus the M/V/C approach.
First of all, we get
per-service control
of a bunch of different
things, namely
things like scaling,
permissions, and access
control.
We also get the enforcement
of good API design.
Now, this can be a
double-edged sword
depending on your situation.
If you're working
on something that's
just a quick hack,
a quick prototype,
you probably don't want
something like this.
You may not want the
microservice pattern.
But if you're working on a
team with dozens or hundreds
of people and you're trying
to build something that
is going to last for years
then having that consistent API
enforcement, that consistent
software engineering practice
can actually be really helpful
in terms of the longevity
of those larger code bases.
And last but not least, this
is one of the key benefits
of microservices.
They give us this language
and stack independence.
So for example, if you wanted
to write an application
and there were
five microservices,
you could write it with
five different stacks,
five different languages.
You could say, I want to
write these two in Java,
I want to write this one in C++,
I want to write that one in C#,
and I want to write
that one in Node.
And as long as they have
a common communication
protocol such as JSON over
HTTP, or protobuf, or something
like that, then you're good.
as long as they can
talk to each other
and they know each
other's APIs then
you can do essentially
whatever you
want in terms of tech stack.
So as an example
of how this works,
here's our canonical
pet store again.
So this is the M/V/C approach.
We have our views on the left,
which again, are front ends.
We have our controllers
in the middle, which
is our business
logic, and then we
have our models on the right.
Now if you look at
this, you'll notice
that there's a lot of complexity
going on between the checkout
method and all these
various models.
In fact, it's connecting to the
user method, the pay method,
and the user cart--
the user model, excuse me-- the
pay method model, and the user
cart model, as well.
So of course, that complexity
means it's very hard for us
to separate those two
components, which kind of makes
us sad.
We can't exactly just
go say, oh, I just
want to reuse
checkout over here,
we have to kind of yank
all those models out of it.
So in terms of what this looks
like in the microservice app
world, you might even
glance at this and say, wow,
this is crazy.
How is this any simpler
than that M/V/C approach?
There's so much
stuff going on here.
But the reality is if you
look at it in the right way,
you'll start to see, OK, well,
the separation of concerns
looks something like this.
So you have your pet service,
which has its own database,
has its own back end
logic, and all it
cares about are
three APIs methods,
list pets, add pet,
and remove pet.
So if it's its own create,
read, update, delete information
storage service,
the beauty of this
is you can change
whatever internal details
of the pet service that you
want to without having to worry
about the rest of the services.
The only time you need to
worry about the other services
is when you're changing
the external facing APIs.
Now of course, because it's
the microservice architecture,
the cart service, same thing.
You could say, OK,
it's running on Java,
I want to code it in Python.
It's running on Python, I want
to move it to C#, whatever.
As long as that API
interface remains the same,
you can change essentially
whatever you want.
And of course, the pay
service is no different.
It's also isolated.
Now, note that
this does call out
to those other microservices.
So you would have to update it
if those microservices changed,
but again, the actual
inner back end logic here
is totally isolated from
what happens elsewhere.
So in terms of bridging the
gap between these two worlds--
between the pre-serverless world
and the serverless world we
live in today--
the first thing you're
going to want to be aware of
is that among many
different problems
there's one really
big one, and that
is this idea of non-scalable
or not quite serverless parts.
If you have parts that are
scalable but not serverless,
they're a little
easier to deal with.
But non-scalable parts mean
that you have to do things
a little bit differently.
So notably what you're
going to want to do
is treat this as essentially
what academics would call
a producer-consumer problem.
Which means you
have a producer, you
have something producing
tasks, and then you
have a consumer that is
consuming those tasks.
Now, your producer
might be serverless,
your producer might be scalable.
But if your consumer
is not, you want
to make sure you don't
overload your consumer with so
many requests that it
buckles under the pressure.
So what you can do is use
Pub/Sub, or Cloud Tasks,
or some sort of serverless
message queue as a task buffer.
And that buffer will throttle
how many tasks are coming out
within a given amount of
time or within a given
set of parameters and ensure
that your downstream service
that can only handle,
say, x tasks a minute
or x tasks per whatever period,
or x tasks at once does not get
overloaded with so
many tasks that it
buckles under the pressure.
And if you need additional
fine tuned logic on top of this
you can use things like App
Engine or Cloud Functions
to give you that
additional consumer logic.
Now, this fine tuned logic might
be that, say, Pub/Sub and Cloud
Tasks don't support exactly the
throttling policies you want
so then you have
to implement them
in some sort of serverless
compute option--
which because it's
serverless can
handle that volume of requests.
Or it might be that you
want to take those requests,
you want to perform some
modification to them,
and only then do you
want to send them
to your downstream service.
Regardless of which one of
those situations you're in,
having this additional
layer of serverless compute
can help you achieve that.
So some rules of
thumb when it comes
to migrating to serverless.
Note of course, this is a
very, very, very complex topic.
If you or your
company are seriously
considering undertaking this
journey, what I recommend
is you check out the
talk by my colleagues
Martin Omander and Adam
Ross, Serverless 202
from Monolith Microservices.
They will take you through
this in a lot more detail
than I am about to now.
But essentially what you want
to remember, first of all,
serverless is not magic.
Things like data dependencies,
things like slow I/O,
things like application
security, these still exist.
They are still concerns.
Serverless is helpful,
but it's not a panacea,
it does not solve everything.
So the second thing, when
you're doing this migration
you generally
speaking want to do it
slowly and piece by piece.
Because if things
break, it's easier
to isolate what the
cause of that breakage
was if you go slow and
don't rush it through.
Now, you also don't want
to go all or nothing
in terms of old approaches.
Like I said, serverless is
more capital E evolutionary
than capital R revolutionary.
So you want to take
advantage of this,
you want to take advantage
of the sort of prior art
that exists in this old
world that will enable you
to leverage that to build your
new serverless architecture.
You don't want to, say,
reinvent the wheel, so to speak.
And last but not
least, when it comes
to making your app totally
serverless this will give you
a slight boost
because at that point,
you won't have to worry about
things like ops anymore more
or less.
You'll have a much
more scalable app
if you're dealing with
non-scalable components.
But the thing to
bear in mind is this
is not a reason to migrate
your application all at once.
The benefit from going
totally serverless
is totally outweighed
by the costs that
may be imposed by migrating
your app all at once if anything
goes wrong.
So definitely despite this, this
is a reason to see it through,
but it's not a reason to rush
that migration process, though.
So now that we've touched
on some of the things that
have changed, some of the 0 to 1
changes in terms of serverless,
I wanted to take a moment
to talk about the capital R
revolutionary aspect
of serverless.
So these are new
patterns that we
can take advantage of that
were not really available to us
before services and
things like functions
as a service showed up.
So the first of
these patterns is
how we do event
processing and automation.
So it used to be that if we
wanted lightweight deployments,
we had to use some
sort of-- well,
to be honest they didn't exist.
The best we could do
is use infrastructure,
which was kind of heavyweight.
Even if we said, OK,
here's this 10 lines
of code, every time I get a
Gmail message, run this code.
That would mean setting up
a whole entire application
for those 10 lines of
code, and it just really
wasn't worth it in
terms of the time
we'd save by writing
all this automation.
Nowadays, what we can do is
increasingly rely on just
individual functions-- single
functions-- and we say,
hey, all I have to do if I want
to run this 10 lines of code
is write the 10 lines
of code and stick it up
on Cloud Functions.
I don't have to worry about, OK,
I wrote the 10 lines of code,
now I have to set up,
say, infrastructure,
I have to set up maybe a LAMP
stack, or something like that.
Another thing I want to touch on
here is the ubiquity of events.
So things like webhooks and
Pub/Sub are common today,
but they're becoming
increasingly
common in the future.
Now, webhooks are common
with external platforms.
What you'll also
see with Pub/Sub
is that you can
access a lot of events
through things like
Stackdriver Logging.
So as we mentioned previously
in that busy wait slide
not all operations will
have access to a Pub/Sub
notification when
they're complete,
but a lot of
operations will instead
log the Stackdriver when
that operation is finished.
So that's something
where you can say,
OK, well I'm going to take
that Stackdriver notification,
I'm going to export
that Stackdriver Logging
notification to
Pub/Sub, and then
Pub/Sub is going to use that
to trigger a Cloud Function.
So essentially-- and there's a
tutorial on this on our site.
If you go to
cloud.google.com/function/docs,
there's a tutorial that walks
you through how to trigger
a Cloud Function in response
to a Stackdriver notification.
So the TLDR here is not only are
webhooks and Pub/Sub becoming
increasingly common, but various
other services like Stackdriver
are also starting
to feed into Pub/Sub
that can essentially
be converted
into Pub/Sub notifications.
And of course, G
Suite is no different.
So G Suite integration is also
becoming easier through things
like REST APIs, and
this type of thing
allows you to take advantage
of line of business automation
and making your day to day
workflow more efficient
using various forms of code.
For those of you that have seen
any of the automation charts
out there, there's a
particularly famous one
from a certain web comic.
But essentially the
way that works is you
have a certain amount
of time that you
save by doing that
automation, like maybe you
run this task x times a
day or x times a week.
It takes y amount
of time, and it
would take you z amount
of time to automate it.
And depending on
those parameters,
it's either worth it or not
worth it to automate that task.
Now, where the serverless
pattern becomes really useful
is if you want to make those
sorts of lightweight G Suite
automations-- like I said,
line of business automations--
you can do that,
because serverless
decreases that z for you.
It decreases the
amount of time that it
would take to set up an
automation for a given task.
Now, rapid prototyping
is another thing
that changes a little bit.
Notably, rapid prototyping
in a serverless world
means that serverless is
great for gluing together
disparate APIs.
So let's say you have a
constellation of really
powerful APIs that do
really interesting things.
Then you can quickly
stitch them together
using things like
Cloud Functions
and our other
serverless offerings
and use that to create easily
scaled apps, which is great
because if you build something
that is the next best thing
but you don't know it yet,
and you tell your friends,
and suddenly you wake
up tomorrow morning
and, like I said, it's on a
national newspaper or something
because it's the best
thing since sliced bread,
then you want to make sure
you can handle that scaling.
And that's why serverless
is great for that kind
of workload.
Now, a corollary that I
wanted to touch on real
quickly is also how
we do market testing.
So if you want to
build something
where you're not sure what
the addressable market for it
is serverless is great
because it will give you,
first of all, a
typically smaller upfront
cost than non-serverless
platforms.
Now, this reduced cost
takes place in two ways.
The first is the compute
cost is pay as you go.
So it's very easy
to say, OK, well
if I don't use as much compute
as I think I'll need to then
I don't have to commit to a
certain amount of compute,
I can just pay as I go.
If you underestimate how many
users you're going to get,
then you can say,
OK, well I didn't
have to pay for 10,000
users worth of compute,
I can just pay for,
whatever, 1,000-- however
many users I actually get.
So you're not on
the hook for that.
Now, if you're in the
opposite situation
where you think you're going
to get, say, 10,000 users
and you end up getting
100,000, or a million,
the scalability
inherent in serverless
means that apps can handle
those sudden explosions
in popularity.
Now of course, you have
to design your application
the right way,
which is why we're
covering design patterns here.
But if you do that then
serverless can generally say,
oh, I understand
you told me that we
were going to get
1,000 users but maybe
we got 10,000 or 100,000.
No biggie, don't worry
about it, I can scale.
So as far as a quick recap of
everything we covered today,
the first thing
to bear in mind is
that serverless is more capital
E evolutionary than capital R
revolutionary.
So many serverless patterns are
essentially updated versions
of older patterns.
And that being said,
serverless does fit neatly
within a lot of these
existing patterns.
So things like
microservice use can
help us increase our
separation of concerns,
which can make our code
easier to maintain and reuse.
Also, these service back
ends are a uniquely good fit
for thick client front ends.
If most of our business
logic is on the front end,
then we can take
advantage of this
to get a uniquely
lightweight back end.
And of course, how we persist
state has kind of changed.
When we're dealing with
serverless compute,
we persist that state
outside of compute.
And of course, things like
caching and persisting
your data source may become
increasingly important.
Now, one more slide that
I wanted to recap on.
So this asynchronous
mindset is, of course, key
in the serverless environment.
So we're starting to see
things like decomposition
take hold where we take all
these tasks, we decompose them,
and then wrap those subtasks
around using various messaging
strategies such as Pub/Sub,
Cloud Tasks, and HTTP.
Typically, you'll see
Pub/Sub and Cloud Tasks.
HTTP is less common, but it
does happen in some cases.
Now of course, the
benefits of this approach.
You get, generally speaking,
a better throughput
and scaling performance
in your application.
You also get reduced
busy wait cost
if you're dealing with
long running operations.
And as I said, not all
of those operations
will conform to that
exact Pub/Sub model.
Sometimes you have to rely
on things like Stackdriver,
or webhooks, or whatever,
but the same logic applies.
Now, if you're dealing
with flow control
because you have to do some
throttling, or retry logic,
or something like
that, perhaps you
have some sort of
non-scalable component
somewhere in your architecture
or some retriable function,
that's where you're
going to want
to use something like Pub/Sub.
And if you need
that compute, you're
going to want to use something
like App Engine or Cloud
Functions.
You may not need that
compute, in which case
you might just use
Pub/Sub, you might just
use Cloud Tasks,
something like that.
Now of course,
serverless opens up
a bunch of new
possibilities, like I said.
It's more capital E evolutionary
than capital R revolutionary,
but it does have its capital
R revolutionary aspects.
So first of all, how we do
lightweight event processing
is increasingly being
modernized through things
like functions as a service.
And second, serverless
this enables
us to do rapid prototyping and
rapid scaling at the same time.
They are no longer
mutually exclusive.
We don't have to say we
want this to scale rapidly
so we have to set up a
bunch of orchestration
and do a bunch of configuration
to get that scalability.
We can just build our
application more or less,
throw it on serverless,
and as long as we
design our app in the
right way it will just
automatically scale up and scale
down with whatever workload
we throw at it.
So that's it for me.
If you have any
questions, please do
reach out to me via email
at faast@google.com.
That's the word fast with two
As, or functions as a service
my team.
And I couldn't figure
out what the T stood
for, it just sounded nice.
And then, of course, you can
hit me up on Twitter @serverl0ss
as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]